you
everyone is cherry I'm on Ches calm and
I just got paired up playing a five-o
game let's see what plaque throws at me
oh all right
Navion defense I'll go with Knight f3
in prima of mode I guess they are
anticipating just 9c3 right out of the
gates
okay
let's put my pawn on c4 hmm they're
pretty content with just being cattle I
imagine
there's not a better place for the Queen
night
I might want to invest this tempo yeah
let's try for our queen well King side
fiend Cadell combating their eventual
attempt to deploy the Queen bishop
okay let's just get on with castles
and enfant aches I'll probably just take
with the night uncover my bishop and
make knight c6 difficult
and on this I thought I could maybe push
the deep on
yeah where's that Nikon let's find out
let's try to rattle this night's post
have a little bit of space No
and yo I want there to be a pond there
so night b4 is going to strike at this
pond for a third time how much of a
bother is that really though
hmm
maybe a little bit of a bother I can
move my night anywhere and be defending
this
let's see night here Bishop to f5
striking it see - hmm I feel like that
shouldn't be too much of a bother let's
see you know it just to prevent Knight
to f5 I want to I want to make sure no
let's go with this if I did night to h4
there's this move and then a knight into
this square at least I'm stopping c4 I'm
expecting Bishop f5
it's getting a bit tactical now on
Bishop f5 where do I go with my bishop
probably f4
night see two rooks see one and that may
be night to d4
he's turning a bit sharp I could then at
that position try for Knight c4 and look
for a--
a d6 push and this Bishop will be
crunched let's see if this happens 9c -
Brooksie 194 Knight c4 with d6 in mind
like has to come up with something fast
I believe otherwise if I get an 83 and
he's forced to go to a six I can't be
good for black this is a passed pawn I
should be looking to push it
so yeah and I mean that would be a
really nice move to get and I'm winning
material immediately if that I could get
this in successfully need a little bit
of support though
okay let's just put this on straight
away the night is within checking
distance let's play here
it's a bit of a bug to work around this
night do I have anything better anything
I'm protected I don't think so let's get
a move in
b5 is likely a critical line I do have
this move I like that I have 93 at least
throwing a punch at something and that
would be a really weakening move so
right now the threat is d6 just winning
the game I have this defendant enough
okay and here we are let me have a look
at just d6 real quick d6 pawn takes
Knight pawn takes Bishop money exchange
I might not
I don't know if I want to give up my
light square bishop though
d6 pawn takes Knight pawn takes Bishop
Bishop takes rook
giving some extra weight to this fiend
keto Bishop I don't want a week in my
light squares
so yeah we're gonna run it like this
I'm sure the computer will be
disagreeing with that decision but okay
I could um go for an approach that
simply challenges blacks best piece
Knight to e2 that comes to mind
this may still be a threat
let's see how they that's probably why
they're going to think here I actually
have a lead on the clock I like that
all pieces except we have just two pawns
exchanged
interesting
okay where to go with the night night a
four move forward strike at c5 or
challenge this monster
I'm gonna go for a simply challenging
blacks best piece and I still am on this
so Knight takes Queen takes I'm fully
developed and I'm throwing this punch
and this this pawn also has some fire on
it
some pressure by my rook maybe tried to
stay ahead on the clock they are at the
two-minute mark did rattle off the first
several moves seem to be all pre move on
so it's black and to come up with here
as well get that pretty moving
save a couple tenths of a second
let's deactivate that
yeah I want to see it a bit more clearly
so what is black really going to do I'm
threatening to win take the night in win
upon okay I guess they have to give up
their best piece and okay so Bishop
there okay
about f3 for a moment or simply rook to
d1
let's go rugby one
you know a night on c4 now that b4 is
and so yes take with the king
Knight c4 okay Bishop to d3 I guess
Bishop d3 Queen f3 I have a minute edge
rare
let's get a quick move in there
Bishop takes and then I'd be on the c5
pawn Knight on f5 this is an extremely
flexible piece from e3 my first thought
was c4 because that is a reliable home
but f5 f5 is a strong post trying to
hunt down my a pond isn't their house on
fire though
starting with this Knight f5 Queen g5
you're really just
for the throats well not really you're
going pawn hunting let's see
Queen g5 I guess you have to defend by
playing Knight to e8
all right
I also have Knight h6
capturing this pawn
a lot of interesting options I don't
think that this could be so bad
okay and maybe I just push my pond
he is past okay
and what about a rook here cutting off
the Queen
on this the night can't move and be
defending that so now there isn't there
isn't a 98 move so I think this has to
be played matin one threat
no tricky sack on f2
here
and they're just running it to mate now
I'm on the rook time pressure clearly a
factor as well night on f5 combined with
the Queen on g5 that's usually a big
problem and I mean in my eyes I see it
as I don't know
close to the level of Oh close to the
worth of a rook you know what to say
with this one let's see let me go into
the analysis board for starters okay
here we go this is the analysis part so
I could paint the board yeah okay so I
mean they were just content with
hmm just these standard moves and sure
they've played this position type many
times before but uh yeah I mean this is
maybe most common but I I didn't want to
obstruct myseif on it as it was played
in the game I wanted my c-pawn to
contribute so this is another approach
Knight f3 d4 c4 and only then Knight to
c3
and I'm just wondering if it's gonna
hold as an advantage for me for the
opening stage at least due to this space
but I'm just wondering if there's any
issue with investing in additional move
to open up a new door for my bishop
because as mentioned I wanted to make
life difficult for black to finish all
complete development with the Queen
bishop
so was a computer want to do right
around here just up bring the bishop out
to eat - I guess I could go to d3 as
well no be a similar evaluation okay so
many different setups but
I went with something fianchetto see
five castles and now it suggests
capturing okay now it's going over to
the knight c6 half pawn advantage okay
knight c6 did I react well okay I did d5
on takes C takes yeah I mean we aren't
definitely going into a pretty critical
line night before I mean I'm throwing a
punch what is black doing they're
reacting and throwing a punch right back
I played 95 Noah great advantage but
okay Bishop f5 and now wants to go to
Queen f3 so is there an issue with what
I played here what's even suggesting g4
that's not the that's not a move that
immediately comes to mind for me one of
those you know you're going all-in type
moves
for weaknesses created there's already
two holes two more created with g4 okay
that didn't enter my mind is there an
issue with what I did Bishop f4 simply
getting a new piece in the ballgame
apparently there is no it's close to
equal suggesting Bishop d6 here
okay let me just have a look at this G
form oh yeah definitely getting pretty
sharp there G for bishops c2 and now
Queen to d2 oh my god I'm just kind of
cringing here because they have this gap
over here on the kingside so many
weaknesses and my queen is now on my
bishops way I don't know does anybody
else cringe when they see this kind of
stuff
alright interesting g4
just take it out maybe one more move
what is it suggesting here for black
Bishop d6 and now have four okay
all right definitely a line I did not
move I did not consider night c2g for
yet again
[Music]
you know what in this position that is
something I I should be considering
because now now this bishop has a
certain restriction placed on his Sue's
the knight goes to see 2g4 have the
knight in Queen covering that
interesting
all right well okay no issue isn't Ric
to see one but yeah so I moved to keep
in mind an ID for it likes Knight c4 and
now after b5
I just wants to take the pond Oh
taking the pond and then following up
with d6 getting the material back and
now these pawns are split yeah and you
know in some variation I I may feel a
little bit more comfortable with giving
up my LightSquared bishop in order to
pick up some material
okay I could have captured on b5 I went
with night to e3 but you still fine move
and after b4 I guess I'm just better
here it does like my move Knight to e2
happy about that and takes Queen takes
is the follow-up what does it want to do
here Bishop to e4 plus 2 that's pretty
serious just giving me up on Knight
takes on takes Queen takes yeah you
don't do that as black you try to stir
up some trouble well you don't give a
pawn away for no compensation so
captured first only then Bishop to e4
mMmmm I could just take the bishop and
then play my knight in to f5
detected night move the night discovered
attack and he can't move he's pinned on
the bishop and the knight from this with
his last move okay
what did I do I got my rook involved
okay it's still holding an advantage but
not nearly as convincing as that line
taking it immediately on e4 Bishop takes
King takes I'm just wondering how I
could have better converted this
position once black went pawn hunting on
the Queen side I mean this really should
be punished I jumped in with Knight f5
Queen takes pawn and I should just be
playing Queen g5 straightaway Queen g5
after this I wasn't 100% sure what to do
here I guess I could just shove my pawn
that did run through my mind um yeah you
know I should be doing this because you
know later on once the Queen picked up a
second pawn then the knight kid may be
moved to forward square and the Queen
would be there to defend against them a
threat on g7 so maybe more to the point
just looking at some more direct stuff
so this is at least the second instance
now where I could have played a bit more
directly and you know what it's that
it's the better choice
Queen g5 threatening mate 98 and then
push d6 looking for d7 and then crashing
through here this is just uh that's the
the greatest attacking combo in the game
Queen and Knight close to the enemy king
so what did I do I just scooped up a
pond it's not bad but not best and then
I pushed d6 still holding an advantage
of plus to rip d4 it does like and after
this Queen g5 and that's going to be the
ball game queen g v g6 and probably
commute x night it's already calling for
me and seven suggesting Queen takes f2
that's when you know it's real bad
enfant takes Knight what are we doing
here
oh I don't know if I would have seen
this I was intending rook takes f5 which
is still winning
but looking at the most direct stuff
rook g4 that would have been a nice
finish you know have these our last
pieces helping out
rook here King f8
clean h6 and the King cannot run because
of this guy and then we have mate that
would have been a cool finish but as it
played out
rook there just hung the rook on d8 and
he had resigned here rook has to block
and I would take okay
interesting game got to see a nice enter
counter game a Scandinavian defense
that's how I knew it when I first was
learning opening names I knew it as the
center counter it's more commonly known
as the Scandinavian defence nowadays
anyhow feel free to leave any feedback
to this video as usual in the comment
section below and I hope you got
something out of it that's all for now
hope you're having a great day take care
bye
you